if it's January it's time for technology
journalist to head for Vegas not so much
for the nightlife as for the new models
and the new shapes on show it's time for
the International Consumer Electronics
Show there's a global event we attract
about 150,000 160,000 people from around
the world actually 14 are outside the
United States we have global companies
here and they're selling to a global
marketplace now ultra high definition
has to be the very best quality to get
the best out of it so we're determined
to keep pushing Netherlands they're
fully immersive so when you see it
you're aware of your surroundings they
yet you see the world in the next few
minutes of full house of new televisions
several driverless cars and a connected
coffee machine as technology comes to
town CES is the biggest technology show
anywhere in the world and every year
televisions take center stage for K is
the big theme this year Ultra High
Definition sets each manufacturer trying
to find a nuance to make there's more
attractive LG here believe in Oh LED
technology with really vibrant colors
and the deepest blacks and for your
convenience this 77 inch set will either
be curved or go completely flat
at the Samsung stand this is their
premium product for 2015 an 88 inch
ultra high-definition set featuring a
new kind of color technology HDR or high
dynamic range you know two-thirds of our
UHD sales in the UK are curved TV so
it's proved to be last year very popular
we believe that's not only because of
the picture quality but because of the
design aesthetics it's one of the most
beautiful items in your home so we think
the popularity will continue to build
Panasonic is also part of this 4k club
in fact a new UHD alliance between the
major manufacturers was announced in
Vegas this year to drive forward formats
and connectivity and content in this
ultra high-def space this CX 850 top of
the range model part of Panasonic's
claimed to be making more for Kay
products than anyone else well about to
come into view is Sony's contribution to
the new 4k sets for 2015 this is a 65
inch ultra high-definition set so thin
at the top of the bezel it's slimmer
than a phone this is all well and good
of course but if you get one of these
sets what are you going to watch on it
well the easy way to do it is through
the likes of Netflix through Amazon into
the instant prime video and sort of
stream it all down the problem for the
infrastructure there is you need a good
broadband connection and in the UK you
know there aren't many houses at the
moment that have 15 make minimum
broadband and that's what you need us is
a bit different you know big cities five
and all that sort of stuff is coming so
that's the real problem you know
panasonic demoed a prototype of a 4k
blu-ray player to out sort of sometime
probably late this year or early next
that will help but it's still you know
it's not today it's not tomorrow it's a
it's a couple of days time at least
there was a lot of in car tech at this
year's CES either manufacturers in their
own right or third party companies
improving the range of technology in our
cars ford for instance gave a major
presentation during the week they've
announced trials of smart mobility the
experiments will take place in london
later this year
now what if you owned a database of your
driving behavior for all the years since
you got your driver's license so for our
next experiment we're looking at that
possibility in London now if you looked
at my lifetime record you know it might
show a few issues of speeding when I was
younger but then it reveals a trajectory
towards good driving behavior that
primarily has lasted throughout my
adulthood now what if this driver score
passport could go with you from car to
car no matter the brand imagine that you
could share that data with insurance
companies to get better rates and in
order understand the business
opportunity and how smaller influences
such as traffic weather and passenger
other passengers affect driver behavior
we're collecting driver data from a
large fleet in London BMW unveiled
active assist you get the car park and
haven't got time to find a space in this
demo you simply press a command on your
connected watch and the car parks itself
ladies and gentlemen this is the
mercedes-benz vision of the car of the
future the most eye-catching revelation
was this car from mercedes-benz the idea
is about designing the entire car around
the advantages of autonomous driving
while making use of the added room you
have in an electric car without the
engine and transmission and a late-night
demo of a concept car driving completely
unaided up the famous Las Vegas Strip
sitting in the limousine of the future
is something really special of course
such a car drives autonomously and
completely emission-free based on these
a world concept there is a completely
new opportunity more space more time to
do something different most people
believe that still some way off a
demonstration of assistance for today's
drivers comes at the valley Oh Stan
they've put together radar data they've
got information coming in from sensors
and an onboard camera and knitted all
that information together to offer a
sort of cruise control plus as soon as
there are landmarks detected as well as
we have objects for example and I'm able
to activate the system like like a
cruise control so I have a set button
have a resume button so as soon as I
press the set button so the car will be
able to steer itself and I can take off
my foot from the pedal as well so the
car is keeping the lane and it's keeping
the distance to the car in front of us
and I have the possibility with the
additional buttons to for example
increase the safety distance or
increased the speed to the speed limit
that's the idea of Cruz for you so it's
not the idea of doing something else get
rid and get to you and in the backseat
it's for me just to to relax my foot
maybe relax my my sitting position a
little bit but but stay focused and stay
in the loop which is which is the the
intention of this cruise for you and
this particular step of development
we're using actually production tender
close to production sensors so we're
using a front camera looking to the
street in front of the car and what we
call a laser scanner a lighter sensor
that is manually scanning the road in
front with a wild angle and we use all
this information from those two senses
and processing this data to understand
in which situation the car is to be able
to control both the speed and steering
of the car to make a real automatic
experience for the driver I think the
problem with clouds and automotive is
that it moves up quite a slow pace I've
been talking to Qualcomm this week and
they saying you know they're putting
chips in cars and modems all the other
stuff but that's three to five years out
then you've got to get the public to buy
the car we don't upgrade them as quickly
as our phones but what I think you will
see in the short term is what they're
calling assisted driving so at the top
of the pile you've got like a Mercedes
prototype but you jump in it's got
swivel seats it drives itself for you
you know we sing some parking cars and
things like that here today there'll be
a lot of focus on making sure you can't
switch lanes without knowing it you know
it's helping you climate your adjusted
cruise control things like this so
within the next ten years before we get
to that everything is driving us you'll
be pretty much letting the car do most
of the things for you whether it's
parking driving on the motorway and
you'll just have to steer and pay
attention well we've had a record number
of major car companies we have ten are
the biggest in the world and the reason
is because the automaker's realize their
future is as technology companies not so
much selling horsepower but selling the
fact that they're keeping the drivers
and the consumers safe and connected and
that requires tremendous changes in
technology so we're seeing the car
developed rapidly into people making
purchasing decisions in the basis of the
electronics in the car the features just
a few years ago is whether a card a cup
holder or none that was the big news and
big deal today it's more about Ken the
car connect me with my smartphone on my
tablet will have collision avoidance
systems will look at me say 45 fall
asleep those kind of issues are being
faced by car makers and they're rapidly
transforming they are in agreement the
next few years they'll see more changes
they did in the last 50 in his
presentation the Intel CEO
brian krzanich deployed drones with new
faster ships inside them which means
they could do collision avoidance this
means they can interpret what's
happening in sensors in the drones and
allows them to avoid hitting humans or
anything else that might come in their
way hence this demonstration of the game
of drone or enclosure let's put to the
drones down and we'll use this drone
here and we're going to play a little
drone ping pong simply moving the drone
between us you see the drone continues
to try and stay in one position but keep
it from going in the oddness avoiding us
at all times
this is aura a latest model from a
company called hobbico this is Gordon
Cockburn who's going to tell us a little
bit about it your drone will come on to
in a moment tell us about the control
surface you've devised for customers
sure actually this is of the latest
innovation in transceivers what this is
a dual frequency band transceiver which
means that when we control the the
flight characteristics of the drone
we're doing it from the 2.4 gigahertz
antenna when we control the video from
the drone we're doing that from the 5.8
gigahertz transceiver that way you
prevent interference from either one of
those two I notice just a touch panel
though that's something I haven't seen
before yeah that's actually brand-new
also an innovative this is a 7-inch
android device touch screen which allows
you to view the video that you're taking
and print first-person view fpv or and
you can set waypoints that will set a
flight routine that allows the quad to
actually fly the routine for you and the
way you programmed it and then bring it
down and set it so we literally say
stock here go there go here go here and
come home and come home in fact you can
tell it when you go here go up 20 feet
shoot video come back down 20 feet go
here a couple of unique features are the
flight time on this which so inside here
there's a 7000 milliamp lipo battery
which flies this plot for about 30
minutes which is a little bit longer
than normal there is a proprietary
camera which is a 12.2 megapixel camera
still camera with 10 any D of HD video
well as you like a GoPro it's not a
GoPro it's not a GoPro it does have the
ability to mount a GoPro though and the
other thing is we're showing here is
just a one axis gimbal but we actually
make it to access and a 3-axis gimbal
we have 3,600 companies exhibiting with
a whole variety of products from health
care products to products that connect
us with each other to products which
only connect with other products and
give us information but these products
are starting to solve world problems now
in agriculture health care creation of
via food and other things which are very
important and these are products with
sensing technology low-cost sensors
being put together by very clever people
and they're serving a real need some of
them will succeed and some will fail but
they are certainly a large number will
succeed and we'll be seeing more and
more of those in the future this device
is a high-end tablet on your head so
it's the equivalent of anything your
Android tablet can do this can do as
dual 720p see-through displays they're
fully immersive so when you see it
you're aware of your surroundings and
yet you see the world I'll take the
shields off so these devices run Android
they will launch with lollipop it has
integrated multi-core processor to
Snapdragon 805 as a three axis gyro magn
accelerometer so not only do I know
where I'm looking also knows what I'm
looking at there's GPS Wi-Fi memory all
built in what do you think you see Jesus
Christ who you think is going to buy
these great question right now we have a
lot of partners in government and
industry to our focus on tellar repair
so you have expert that's far away from
where the damaged product is a user can
wear it through the camera in the center
see the device and someone can augment
how to repair that device I wear this I
get a 65-inch equivalent display in a
field of view so I could watch my movies
it's private no one sees what I'm seeing
at some sunlight readable its body
independent and yet I'm aware of my
surroundings so there's a lot of use
cases I've been coming to the show I
think it's my 12th show so about 15
years it's quite a lot here and the
thing I've noticed is that over that
time it's gone from the big
manufacturers the Sony's the samsung's
of this world dominating the show to
what I'm all is calling the
democratization of tech is that you know
you and I could with a couple of quid
set up you know and
idea get it funded on a crowdsourcing
site bring it here spend not much to get
a stand and start showing us and
certainly walking around the show this
week I've noticed there's a lot of small
companies now whether they going to
succeed but they're going to take on the
Sony's of this world it's yet to be seen
but it's interesting that very much like
the internet ten years ago pretty much
anybody can now set up a tech company
and make a difference if they've got
that idea so Lupe has invented a brand
new technology that uses magnetic
transmission capabilities to transmit a
magnetic pulse through a loop of wire
hence lupe and through sending
electrical current through a loop of
wire creates a magnetic field and if we
flip that magnetic field back and forth
we can emulate what happens when you
swipe a card and that transmission
allows us to now digitize every single
card that's in our wallet and allow us
to transmit to 90 plus percent of
existing point-of-sales without changing
the point of sale we put a lot of
security to make sure that we protect
the cardholder information and protect
the card holders so that we prevent
people from trying to skim your card for
example every device is individually
serial unique ID and every device can be
bound to only one account so if you have
a wallet account you have to identify
yourself first we can find a device to
your account and only you can load your
own cards and we also check the names of
your payment card to make sure it
matches the account so that you don't go
and took somebody else's card and load
it into your own
so a lot of security precautions to
protect your card your information this
shows not just for the big international
companies it's also for the smaller
firms or startups now imagine a
situation in a being crowded place like
this and you lost control of your young
children would you walk technology to
hell out so it's the thought of not
necessarily knowing where your children
are when you just turn your back it's
not necessarily when the miles away it's
probably those few seconds and hopefully
not much longer with having a child
angel on that you actually now will be
able to know where they are we've got
batteries either side we've got three
antenna to do what we needed to do so
the GPS Wi-Fi gsm the shape has been
shaped to fit a child's risk cuz a
child's wrist isn't round so we've we've
built it for that the strap has got the
alarm in so when this is connected like
that and put through the loop the minute
the child does data they don't have to
take it off the alarm goes off on the
smartphone or tablet or whatever it
might be so that's in there all of the
other functionality is built in our the
unlimited geofencing etc but this is key
the personalization why would they want
to wear one children apart from the fact
that they want the parents woman's
weight is because they could clip on
whatever they want to so this happens to
be one of our angel characters this is
Gabriel so if you want it to be a boy
angel you could click that on but you
might also want to click on your
favorite football store or your favorite
theme park ride or whatever it might be
every morning they get off or whenever
their parents want them to wear it they
can make it whatever they want to make
it at the show if you walk around there
are a lot of sensors and a lot of things
and you are just looking at them going I
really don't understand there are some
clever ones there's a company called
smarter making a wireless Wi-Fi
connected coffee machine which is
connected to a service called if this
then that which means that you can
connect it to other things so a good
example of that would be I've gotta
sleep tracker I haven't slept very well
it sends data to the Internet to the
cloud and makes my coffee a little bit
stronger when I wake up in the morning
to perk me up I think it's the
new here and that we're going into now
everybody wants to save time everybody
wants to be more efficient to connect a
coffee machine with your smartphone it
just means that you're you're able to do
things in the background there's no more
waiting around so I can freshly brine my
cup of coffee whilst i'm still in bed
that saved me 10 minutes the time I've
gone downstairs I'm greeted with a fresh
cup of coffee so it's just a perfect way
to start your day when out CS i'm joined
by scott mcgregor whose CEO of broadcom
thank you for spending some time with us
today good to be the Internet of Things
has been a buzz word for a year or two
but everyone tells me it's really come
into its own this year is that right I
think here at CES you're seeing a lot of
new devices and many of them were sort
of in the experimental phase for the
last couple years I think they're now
starting to get actually useful they're
going to be a lot of more nichy kinds of
applications like gardening specific
things or pet specific things and so
forth but i think the use cases are
starting to look better it's now you've
got demo here about the sort of the home
of the future if you like and some of
the technology you are working on and we
have to say you're a few years ahead of
us aren't you in terms of your
technologists are already trying to
envision what will become the needs of
two years three years hands rod come
makes the micro electronics that go into
a lot of devices you see and here at CES
so in a way we're two to three years
ahead of what you'll see in the future
so one of the big problems that
consumers have is that they get all this
electronic kit and putting it all
together is very difficult you know it
doesn't know it's not all compatible
it's hard to make it all work and play
so what we have here is a demo of all
the different kinds of devices you can
have in your house and how do you tie
them all together all the TVs all the
set-top boxes your car charging you know
electrically in the garage you come into
your house it recognizes that it's you
in front of the TV sets so you see the
channels that you like it recognizes
there isn't an adult in the room so you
don't watch the naughty channels that
the kids would like to watch so all of
this stuff can happen automatically but
it's very difficult for consumers to
make it all play together and we enable
this kind of
connectivity and putting it all together
that our customers the major carriers
and stuff like that can then use as a
product that you could buy as it is that
a problem in your industry that of
course firms compete to come up with new
ideas but in some spheres you actually
want people to collaborate not compete
in our industry we believe in standards
it's really made it possible and there
are many standards like Bluetooth and
Wi-Fi and some of the video recording
standards that make it possible to
interchange content and data so we
believe in that we work with our
competitors to do that creates a bigger
market for everybody and as a consumer
you just go crazy when you can't get
stuff to work together and so part of
our job is to make it possible and the
actual backbone of all this the internet
itself the connectivity behind the
scenes for us as consumers we hook it up
at the office or at the house and we
expect it to work how is that going to
have to change as the amount of data
flying around can only go up and up so a
lot of people don't have a good view of
how all the data actually gets to their
house and one of the things we do at
broadcom is we provide the technology
that your telephone carrier or that your
other Internet service provider has in
their data centers in their
infrastructure to make that work and
that's going through orders of magnitude
expansion for example we're working on
products and we have behind you right
now a product that does a gigabit per
second or more of data into the house
okay so dramatic improvement you know
one or two words of magnitude absolutely
in the next few years you'll see that so
today you can only do that with things
like fiber technology you'll be able to
do that with more traditional cable
technology going forward and that's
again orders of magnitude more internet
speed allowing much higher quality
content you buy that brand new 4k TV set
you're going to see great-looking
content on it and in the light of our
conversation we're holding just a few
weeks after Sony Corporation suffered
its embarrassments about well poor data
management the hack and everything else
do you have to bake in security at this
kind of granular level at the street
level and around the home or is this
something of an add-on we then have to
worry about as a consumer security has
to be in place at many levels so at
broadcom we provide in here
security in the devices so you can't
intercept transmissions in decode them
easily so in Wi-Fi for example it's all
encrypted fairly seriously encrypted we
provide other systems that look at
packets protect against intrusion
protect against viruses and things like
that at the infrastructure level on the
other hand if you accidentally give
somebody your password we can't protect
against that however we can do some
things like recognizing its you rather
than require you remember a password so
working with companies that do
fingerprint sensors biometrics we can
tell by the way you hold a device
whether it's you or not so there's a lot
of ways to do that for example a TV
remote control each person holds a
device a different way slightly
different movements how they rotate it
enough to you identify that can tell the
difference between the people in a
household so for example if I pick up a
remote control and I want to see my
channels it can tell that it's me
holding the remote control so these are
the kinds of security that are much more
user-friendly relying on people to
memorize 50 passwords you know what they
do they write them on the back of the
keyboard that's not very secure so she's
the same security needs to become more
inherent to what we do ourselves and
what we have with us and not more these
artificial things about remembering
passwords big theme of the show is the
automated space the automatic car the
driverless car is that an area you think
is just on the edge of a research
project or is that going to be real I
think it's going to be an interesting
experiment for our society to go to
driverless cars and what that means for
insurance companies and for yielding it
stop signs and things like that I think
it'll definitely happen though it's
great for safety it's great for user
convenience what it will mean though is
that now you're going to have a lot of
time in the car where you're not driving
so entertainment becomes a much higher
priority and so we see the car as the
living room on wheels and Broadcom
provides a lot of the technology for the
living room so we're very interested in
that we have a demo here today about how
we can increase the wiring performance
in a car to get high speed internet
throughout the car we're working on ways
to provide all of the content you have
in your living room how do you get that
in the car
and you know it moves beyond from just
keeping the kids from fighting in the
back seat you know too if the drivers
not driving the car while the driver now
might want to watch a movie or do
something else so we'll help that happen
just one thing on the science of all the
chips that you guys make for years we
seem to have this question about are we
reaching the limit of what silicon can
do are we well I think humankind has
shown its inventiveness for a long time
so have we reached the limit I doubt it
we are reaching some limits in that the
devices we're creating now are using
single atoms or small numbers of atoms
to do things and it's very hard to have
half an atom yes that's kind of we reach
the end of that road you reach the end
at some point however it doesn't mean
that innovation will stop we'll start
instead of going two dimensionally
shrinking things will start going in
three dimensions okay we'll start using
groups of things for example if you
can't make a single computer any faster
well you can harness a thousand
computers together and that used to be
craziness that you would harness a
thousand computers together but if you
can make a computer for ten cents
harnessing a thousand of them together
doesn't sound that far-fetched I'm
wondering in the experience of the last
couple of months with the sony problems
whether we have any misgivings that as
we become ever more connected so we have
to be worried that that connectivity
maybe at some point under threat we're
certainly with every new technology
there are benefits and there are costs
and I think we have to increase the
dialogue where we talk about privacy and
security as issues we will always have
to deal with in our lifetime at the same
time though we are always getting
additional benefits for example at the
internet and intelligent occations and
wireless connect us as never before they
give us benefits in safety and security
now I could be anywhere in the world and
I could watch what's going on in my home
I can get information on the temperature
the moisture whether doors are opening
whether anyone's there whether lights
are on these products didn't exist years
ago and there's always trade-offs as
technology comes forward from the
invention of fire itself and the
discovery of it there is a danger that
you would get burned so too with
technology that's it for this week
remember to keep up on all the breaking
tech stories on our iPad app
smartphone applications Sky News calm
and our YouTube channel from me Martin
Stanford at the CES show in Las Vegas
goodbye
you